so that now brings us into a realm where
rather than all of this stuff about we
have the same basic building blocks as
every other species out there but we use
it uniquely now looking at realms where
there is simply no precedent nothing
else out there does the sort of stuff
that we do and giving two examples here
first one is personified in the
personification on this these are two
quotes from this wonderful book by Ruth
Gendler called the book of qualities
which each page is this personification
of the different emotion and they're
wonderful they're great and what you
have are these like very strange ways of
talking about compassion or anxiety or
anything and we understand what she's
talking about we understand because we
do things like have symbols and
metaphors and parables and analogies and
figures of speech and this is something
that no other species has out there and
we can suddenly understand all sorts of
things we know that when the captain of
the ship isn't asking for more than just
hands when he's asking for the hands to
be on deck we know that the hands
represent something we understand that
Kafka's metamorphosis was not a book
about entomology we understand that a
piece of cloth can represent deep deep
societal values and it could be deeply
offensive if somebody else is trying to
burn that flag and we also understand
that the right person putting the right
collection of ink on a piece of paper
and what that music stands for is
Napoleon getting his ass kicked outside
of Moscow and what we also understand is
the phrase Napoleon getting kicked there
outside of Moscow what that actually
stands for was thousands and thousands
of soldiers dying cold and hungry far
from home we can do things that are
astonishing and unique in the realm of
metaphor but what's most interesting
about it is how our brain processes it
because we have in some ways a classic
mammalian brain but we've got to handle
something utterly unprecedented here the
notion of metaphors and symbols so how
does the brain do it it turns out in a
very unexpected
way okay first example you and in this
case you could be virtually any mammal
on earth you have just eaten a piece of
food that is rotten it is spoiled it is
fetid as god knows what it tastes
absolutely disgusting and in the process
of spitting it out there's a partier
brain that activates something called
the insula cortex which has a lot to do
with gustatory processing it tells you
when you've just eaten something
disgusting but also activates if you
smell something disgusting it also
activates uniquely in us if we think
about something we find to be gustatory
disgusting and suddenly you can have
people activating their insula usually
in brain scanning machines when they
contemplate eating all sorts of stuff
that in your particular culture counts
as disgusting and this is all mediated
by this part of the brain the insula
which is just underneath the surface of
one of the cortices there and is totally
cool and it's connected with gustatory
and that's how it works in mammals but
then we've to contemplate being
disgusted by something else we
contemplate being disgusted by what
humans are willing to do to each other
and we wallow in it and we think about
it and we come up with ideas like just
hearing about this makes me sick to my
stomach just knowing people can do
things like that makes me want to puke
makes me feel queasy I just have a dirty
taste in my mouth sits here and we'd
have a metaphor with it and when we are
contemplating moral disgust the same
part of the brain activates you sit
somebody down and get them to recount a
moral failing of theirs and this part of
the brain activate we not only do
gustatory disgust we do moral disgust
with the same part of the brain how
could that be because when we evolve
this capacity for moral disgust we
didn't come up with a new brain region
we just forced this insula to expand its
portfolio and in some way the brain
handled this very abstract concept in
this totally literal way this is another
version of eating disgusting spoiled
food a certain concreteness there and
how the brain handles it
next example somebody pokes your finger
with a pin and it hurts and there's all
sorts of parts of your brain that
activate that tell you things like it
was a pin rather than my fingers on fire
there's other parts saying it was your
finger rather than your toe it was
telling you the intensity all sorts of
like pain ohmmeter very concrete areas
but then there's a part of the brain
called the anterior cingulate which is
more involved in the evaluative aspects
what does it mean that I'm having this
pain or sit and contemplate right now
your finger being poked like that and
think again you will activate your
entire anterior cingulate it will be
this part of the brain that gets active
and it responds not only to you being in
pain but you imagining you're being in
pain now what you do instead is ask the
person to sit there and contemplate the
finger of their beloved being poked and
the same part of the brain activates on
a very literal concrete level this part
of the brain feel someone else's pain
this is a part of the brain that is a
core of empathy no wait a second this
part of the brain tells you whether you
were being eaten by piranhas on your
feet or whether your shoes are too tight
this part of the brain tells you whether
it's good news or really bad news and
all this value of stuff this part of the
brain tells you when somebody else is
feeling pain and when we came up with
this metaphor of psychic pain we jammed
it into the same old place where we had
calluses in sending information up to
our pain centers and very interestingly
this part of the brain is hyperactive in
people with major clinical depression
people who are pathologically feeling
the pains of everything and
fascinatingly there's a neurotransmitter
called substance P and substance P has a
whole lot to do with anterior cingulate
function and it's got something to do
with pain pathways and everybody's known
this for centuries and there are drugs
which will block the action of substance
P and they often have antidepressant
action so here we have the part of your
brain that does physical pain when we
developed apps try
capacity to read about refugees on the
other side of the planet and psychic
pain gets processed in the same way more
examples it's a brilliant recent work
totally amazing study that was done
recently here's what's done researchers
got the volunteers to come in and in the
first scenario they asked the person to
tell them something about what their
high school was like or some such thing
as part of this psych study and
afterward they say well we can't pay you
for doing this but just as a token do
you want this new fountain pen or do you
want this package of hand wipes and
those are the two geegaws and you know
fifty-fifty now instead the subjects
come in and they're asked to tell about
a time where they had a grave moral
failure a time where they did something
awful afterward you say well we can't
marry you but here's a choice you can
have Penn or the Hat and a way
disproportionate percentage asked for
the hand wipes they're feeling dirty
afterward they want to cleanse
themselves and in a remarkable
elaboration what they now did in this
study was everybody had to come in and
tell about their sins and then afterward
half the people were given an
opportunity to go to the bathroom and
wash up half were not they come back to
the room and as things were staged some
assistant comes into the room holding a
whole stack of papers and trips and
drops all of them if you've just washed
your hands after talking about your sins
you are less likely to get up and help
this person pick this stuff up you have
washed away your sins you have washed
away this incentive to help someone else
all this suggesting something about so
pure has something to do with how we
think about moral failures and what sort
of impair imperatives come out of that
absolutely wild
another example here in this study
people were coming up to some psych
department and there University and it
was gonna be some puzzle solving who
knows what and unknown to them of course
the actual experiment took place in the
elevator get in the elevator and there's
somebody waiting there ready to get in
also is holding a whole
stack of papers and barely and holding
on to a drink and the person says can
you do me a favor can you just hold on
to this because I got to pull these
together and half the cases the person
the subject was asked to hold a cup of
warm hot coffee and half the cases it
was a cup of iced coffee
a hot cup or a cold cup then they go in
and they do this very brief test and
then afterward they're asked to assess
what was the the tester like how did you
feel about them hold the warm cup in
your hand and you were more likely to
assess this person as having had a warm
personality we confuse the part of the
brain that's telling us something about
temperature here is somehow confusing no
no no no that's a metaphor a warm
personality this person there's a total
ice queen whatever and we'll freeze all
of Narnia over and just because you were
holding the cup of ice and our brain has
a lot of trouble telling those apart
another example here subjects were being
put through a study and they were
sitting in a chair like the comfy sofa
on the left or this stark one on the
right there and they're reading
somebody's job resume and or some some
scenario and they're asked to make
assessments afterward sit in the chair
on the right and you are more likely to
judge the people you read about as being
more serious having more gravity about
them being more focused you're sitting
there and where you're sitting is
changing your perception and what we
have they didn't ask in the study there
but I think what we can almost certainly
agree is that people who sat chairs on
the right are more likely to perceive
people as being hard asked and again
metaphors being mixed here's one of the
most fascinating ones this was a recent
study where people read a stretch of a
page about American history and it was
either written in a conventional way or
a way that very much personified the
United States as an organism it was in
America's infancy that it first began to
do what it was after the Civil War that
America had a growth spurt wherever so
either neutral or in a personified way
and in the study before you read this
you either read
something neutral or you read something
about the health risks of bacteria and
what they showed was if you were
thinking about the United States is
being personified and you've just read
about scary bacteria in questionnaires
afterward you are more hostile to
immigration you are more likely to view
immigrants as dangerous pathogens coming
in this is an absolutely wild way in
which this metaphor stuff is abstract as
you can get is inadvertently being
processed by the brain in the most
concrete little ways and out comes all
sorts of ways in which we are subtly
being shaped by this phenomenon and a
lot of researchers in the field of sort
of neurobiology of moral behavior note
that essentially what we do with our
conscious decision making is justify the
intuitions and the visceral responses we
have already had and some of the time
this is disastrous in Rwanda during the
Hutu genocide against the Tutsis one of
the figures of propaganda that the hoots
who used was Tutsis in on the radio and
the newspaper and anything were never
referred to as Tutsis they were only
referred to as cockroaches and you get
people to a point we're hearing a
reference to an entire other people he
activates your insular cortex and you've
got somebody who's just ready to jump in
with the bloodshed but some of the time
we can use that for a better outcome the
political scientist Robert Axelrod has
written a lot about this and written
about the powers of symbols in terms of
solving world problems and the power of
symbolic concessions and what he does
are studies that show things like he
will talk to some really right-wing
military Israeli leaders and some major
radical Hamas leaders and he will get
quotes out of them like the Hamas person
saying if peace is going to go forward
these Raley's have to at least once say
we got screwed in 1948 it was not fair
that our land was given away and the
Israeli Hawks they're saying they're
saying if peace is going to go forward
they've got to get that protocols of the
Elders is
and crap out of their high school
textbooks not we need to get a better
deal with water rights or mineral rights
or how armed the Palestinian police
force can be or any of that but purely
about symbolism and what he emphasizes
is how powerful these symbols are not
one to previously warring nations figure
out how to share a river but when the
king of one comes to the funeral of the
leader of another and pays attention to
the religious symbols of there's huge
potential power there